welcome to this video playing Tasha Yar
from France 2,500 pretty high rating
it's no title here oops
no name I guess no name at all okay so
let's go to the Z mesh again check my
results are pretty pretty encouraging
lots of people play this crappy d5 setup
strangely enough okay but here's some
playing a more conventional setup so
this is quite uncommon order
okay so he's playing for a quick attack
on c4 this as possible but it's
dangerous for black I can even play e5
here not Queenie - it's both them it's
both possible high five yeah not easy
okay let's do this a lot spent ages
[Music]
yeah in fact you can play e5 and then
something like g-form
it's not theoretical position I'm not
saying that but in similar positions
I've seen this even g4 takes Knight g5
it's a very very much in your face
approach but sometimes it says it's it's
working okay but it's very much
dependent on his move now
he's also got night b3 as a possible
idea so this g4 stuff hmm I think I need
to have a push up I need to have this
bishop so a flight we should be three
first but g4 is something that is in
intriguing I think I'm going to do that
oh no not after d5 after the five five I
don't know maybe maybe especially after
this
I can't go no GFI first back come on
let's let's have some fun here
that's Knight g5 what I'm wondering is
Queen d7 cd5 Bishop d3 Detex is six
Bishop d2 takes on d7 hmm the knight are
strapped and if I go g4 here g4 yeah
that's probably nonsense okay I can take
him this is not bad at all let's let's
do that that's fun on h6 I'm going to
take on f5 sacrifice the piece
okay well this isn't this isn't so so on
the geotech s it may seem mad sir it's
dangerous I do I believe
yes I thought I take on f5 but maybe I
didn't have a drive
yes also good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
very unclear position cook age six and
g7 and whatever I don't really think
it's maybe it's not objectively working
but it's a it's quite it's quite
dangerous yeah Luke h8 and and meat
somehow I need to have the rook here I
mean this is wrong I need I need to have
a pawn on d6 this is the the key point
and then go into the H file and it's
made on h8 like here threatening Group H
a tent and mate this is difficult to
defend
what did what the recce position but
it's just the threat rook h8 has made
maybe he needs to me to move the rope
here again threatening look edge inmate
and no I can maybe maybe I need I need
to look on the fo
and they'd look everyone quickly if he
takes rook everyone is very dangerous
and rook F six coming he takes the
bishop
I could have I could have just taken a
fall this was much easier
oh no no came this was a very simple win
just drew back Weiner for Queen f6 okay
so I hope this wins as well and I really
I think it was at least a creative way
to play so I think it deserves deserve
something I came
[Music]
check
[Music]
yeah I was a shame what a shame
Karina Ford was just winning after all
this and I don't really care so much
about the point or losing or something
it's just if you really play a creative
game but I feel it should be rewarded
but it's all in your own it's all your
own fate I mean if you play play battle
II you get punished
[Music]
yeah this is bloody bishops hanging
check
[Music]
what a shame and just queena forward he
resigns it's just over very easy just
very very easy
[Music]
yeah this is just lost here I mean I'm
continuing but it's it's just lost
[Music]
hmm
time warning
ah what the heck of care is sine white
resigns I'm such an idiot
I mean what a shame I really I really I
really like it what what I did yeah it's
probably not not correct but it's just
it's just it's just interesting yeah
okay the computers of course merciless
it wants to play rook a to and win
instantly okay yeah I didn't see that
okay but what I saw and what was really
easy was this was okay also this and now
just Queen a for this is what I just saw
too late I mean this looks like a cool
move but it's just useless and this is
this is simple and easy kid we have six
and over like just resins and insides
it's gone yeah and also but if we wanted
this interesting attacking play correct
or not but it was interesting they are
not castles was it's a the kind of cool
things that you want to play it's still
winning for white that's still winning
for white rook h7 ah look h7 Queen h6
this is even a mate okay
didn't see that one and TM I'm just
fishing group age 4 group age 4 wins the
Queen okay what the heck did I do that
Group H 4 wins the Queen am I completely
brain-dead I need to break here okay
what it wins the Queen ah oh my god
probably I should drink a beer Wow okay
and TM his his escapes asking I just
have a couple of checks here but nothing
nothing serious well this is a draw
according to the computer
Bishop c5 is it wrong okay that's cute
okay I need a break
thanks for watching